[Música]
sexta jornada de la Cumbre climática de
la ONU que se desarrolla en Egipto
marcada por la presencia de Estados
Unidos en su intervención el presidente
Joe biden Se comprometió a ayudar en la
transición energética y a reducir las
emisiones de carbono para el 2030
Tenemos reporte desde charming Shake
las tropas de Ucrania retomaron el
control de la ciudad de gerson tras La
retirada del ejército ruso sin embargo
Moscú mantiene que su salida militar no
cambia el estatus de la región
anexionada Rusia
el oficialismo y la oposición de
Venezuela se encontraron en París en el
marco del foro para la paz liderado por
el presidente francés Emmanuel macron
estuvieron presentes también los
presidentes de Argentina y Colombia
Gustavo Petro destacó la violencia
causada por el narcotráfico y la guerra
contra las drogas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Egipto porque
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden estuvo en charmershake donde se
desarrolla recordemos la co-27 en Egipto
se reunió con el presidente abdelfatá al
Sisi para abordar la relación entre el
Cairo y Washington así como problemas de
seguridad regional mientras que en su
alocución ante la Cumbre climática
bailen Se comprometió a ayudar en la
transición energética y a reducir las
emisiones de carbono para el año 2030
sin embargo no concretó ninguna medida
en referencia al fondo de daños y
pérdidas que pide el sur global
particularmente los países menos
industrializados y menos contaminantes
nuestras enviadas especiales a
charmershake María Clara calle y marina
Colorado con los detalles
tres grandes compromisos hizo el
presidente Joe biden aquí en la cop 27
la primera es la creación del plan de
acción sobre el metano con el que se
espera que Estados Unidos reduzca en un
87% sus emisiones de este gas de aquí a
2030 otro de los anuncios es duplicar el
respaldo que da al fondo de adaptación
para llegar a 100 millones el doble de
lo que prometió en la Cup 26 en Glasgow
y otro de los anuncios es dedicar 150
millones para acelerar el plan de fondo
de emergencia para adaptación y
resiliencia y dentro de ellos se cuentan
500 millones para ayudar a Egipto a una
transición energética algo que hacen en
Alianza con la Unión Europea y Alemania
el presidente biden no habló sin embargo
de una de las promesas esperadas que era
reducir las emisiones de los
contratistas federales en Estados Unidos
por otra parte vaiden defendió la ley
para la reducción de inflación con la
que dedicó 170 mil millones de dólares
para combatir el cambio climático sin
embargo los activistas estadounidenses
dicen que claramente sí es el plan más
grande en la historia pero porque nunca
ha habido otro y que este monto
representa tan solo el 4% de lo que se
destina al presupuesto de defensa
el problema principal de la ley para la
reducción de inflación es que no hace
nada para enfrentar nuestros problemas
de combustibles fósiles en el mundo solo
destina dinero para la energía renovable
pero también afianza el interés por los
combustibles fósiles le da a las
compañías de combustibles fósiles las
posibilidades para ser más nuevos
arrendamientos para explorar gas y
petróleo y Esa es la dirección opuesta
de donde Necesitamos ir
lo que le pedimos a Estados Unidos es
que cree una especie de mecanismo de
financiación que pueda hacerle frente a
los daños y las pérdidas y comienza a
financiar las clases de reparación que
son necesarias por parte de los grandes
contaminadores de Estados Unidos y que
han afectado a las comunidades que poco
hicieron para causar el problema
y precisamente en el marco de la cop 27
Franz 24 les ofrece una serie de
reportajes relativos a la crisis
climática este episodio está centrado en
Ecuador donde el retroceso del 50% de
los glaciares volcánicos es una de las
consecuencias más evidentes del
calentamiento global el informe es de
nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
Luisa Machado centinela en el parque
nacional su tarea de proteger el volcán
es cada vez más ardua el deshielo avanza
cada año y atenta con dejar sin agua a
la población que habita en la capital
ecuatoriana el retroceso es de 20 a 25
metros por año y eso es realmente
preocupante es una cantidad de retroceso
muy muy pronunciada que que a la vez
afecta tanto a la producción de agua
Además del deshielo el agua que se
consume en la capital ecuatoriana
proviene de esta laguna de origen
glaciar a 35 kilómetros del volcán
antisana la Cri que la escasez de
lluvias amenazan estos reservorios
naturales reduciendo sus niveles de agua
también preocupa Patricio Muñoz
guardaparques quien conoce el lugar
desde hace 40 años para proteger la
diversidad vegetal siembra huertos que
aspira convertir en 5000 nuevas plantas
al año la vegetación muere
constantemente por la falta de lluvias y
el incremento del sol se contabilizaban
hasta
300 días de lluvia no y apenas teníamos
un mes
entre medio seco o medio húmedo hoy
totalmente ha cambiado
me agrada que la zona de amortiguamiento
aún la tenemos además de la flora
también la fauna está sufriendo de los
estragos de los cambios de temperatura
ante la migración de muchas especies
Luisa vigila que el cóndor ave típica
nacional en peligro de extinción
permanezca en su hábitat natural
camino al antisana el desgaste glaciar
devela sus capas rocosas a kilómetros de
distancia y confirma nuevas amenazas las
microplásticos Y eso también es un
factor que durante años ya sea por
actividades turísticas por actividades
antrópicas y el mismo ambiente ya tiene
microplásticos y están depositados en el
Nevado
son 120.000 hectáreas de áreas
protegidas amenazadas de desaparecer
este parque natural poblaciones enteras
quedarían sin agua y ya no existiría el
ecosistema más rico de Ecuador vamos
ahora con noticias relacionadas con la
guerra en Ucrania porque el ejército
ucraniano retoma la localidad de gerson
tras La retirada total de las tropas
rusas decenas de civiles celebraron la
llegada de las fuerzas ucranianas a la
ciudad recordemos que jerson era la
mayor urbe bajo control de Moscú y un
punto geoestratégico de la sin embargo
Rusia mantiene que la salida militar de
la ciudad no cambia su estatuto de zona
anexionada según Moscú tras su retirada
de jerson No quedan tropas rusas al
oeste del sistema fluvial que divide
Ucrania el mayor repliegue organizado de
las tropas rusas desde que abandonaron
la región de kiev ha sido celebrado por
el presidente ucraniano como una
victoria para su país
Hoy es un día histórico estamos
recuperando el sur de nuestro país
estamos recuperando gersones a partir de
ahora nuestros Defensores están en las
afueras de la ciudad Solo falta un poco
más y luego empezar a entrar pero las
unidades especiales ya están en la
ciudad
quiero hacer una mención especial a esos
soldados mercenarios y colaboradores
rusos que fueron abandonados en gerson y
otras ciudades del sur la única
posibilidad de que ustedes se salven es
Rendirse al cautiverio ucraniano de
conformidad con la y las normas
internacionales
vamos ahora a Francia porque las 230
personas a las que Italia impidió
desembarcar en sus costas llegaron al
puerto francés de Tulum Este viernes lo
hicieron a bordo del barco de rescate
Ocean viking un tercio de las personas
rescatadas permanecerán en Francia pero
en centros administrativos de donde no
podrán salir mientras se transmiten su
solicitudes de asilo según anunció el
ministro del interior francés el resto
de personas rescatada serán dirigidas a
otros países de la Unión Europea pero
mientras la falta de alternativas
migratorias legales para llegar y
permanecer en territorio comunitario
continúa en el fondo de la cuestión
Francia acusó a Italia de responder de
forma inhumana a una situación de
emergencia humanitaria
y en otras noticias en el primer día de
la Cumbre de lacean la asociación de
Naciones del sudeste asiático los
líderes acordaron comprometerse con los
grupos de la oposición de myanmar frente
a la ausencia de aplicación del plan de
paz negociado en abril del año pasado
con la junta militar Laura él tiene los
detalles
Un año más La silla de nyanmar estuvo
vacía en la apertura de la Cumbre del
asean los líderes militares Siguen sin
poder asistir a las reuniones
importantes de la organización y se
arriesgan a ser excluidos
definitivamente si no empiezan a aplicar
el plan de paz acordado en abril de 2021
dentro del bloque Indonesia ha sido una
de las principales voces pidiendo una
acción más dura contra la junta de
myanmark
está profundamente decepcionada la
situación en mi armar está empeorando no
hay avances significativos en la
implementación del consenso de los cinco
puntos y luego no hay compromiso de la
junta no debemos permitir que la
situación en mi amar defina a la Asia
mi hermana ha entrado en una espiral de
conflicto sangrientos desde que los
militares derrocaron el gobierno de
anson suquía en febrero de 2021 el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez condenó de nuevo la
escalada de violencia y la crisis en
materia de Derechos Humanos que vive el
país
los ataques indiscriminados contra la
población civil pueden constituir
crímenes de guerra según el derecho
internacional reitero mi llamamiento a
las autoridades de myanmar para que
liberen a todos los presos políticos y
pongan en marcha inmediatamente un
proceso para volver a la transición
democrática Este es el único camino
hacia la paz
Security las potencias occidentales han
impuestos sanciones a la junta mientras
la violencia se ha intensificado en las
últimas semanas con mortíferos ataques
militares aéreos contra objetivos
civiles
y en París se encontraron representantes
del oficialismo y de la oposición
Venezolana en el marco del foro por la
paz liderado por el presidente francés
Emmanuel macrón el encuentro lo
protagonizaron el presidente de la
asamblea nacional de Venezuela Jorge
Rodríguez y el opositor Gerardo blaite y
además estuvo presenciado por los jefes
de estado de Colombia y de Argentina
Gustavo Petro y Alberto Fernández que
junto con macron abogaron por la
reanudación de los diálogos venezolanos
por otro lado los mandatarios también
abordaron la violencia causada por el
narcotráfico recordemos que en
reiteradas ocasiones Petro ha reprochado
a Estados Unidos El fracaso de la
llamada guerra contra las drogas
escuchemos al presidente colombiano
la región vio más violenta del mundo hoy
no es Ucrania
no es el medio oriente no es Irak no es
Libia la región más violenta del mundo
es tan América son las rutas
clandestinizadas del transporte de la
cocaína ciudad y país por donde pasa va
dejando un reguero de sangre que se
cuenta por centenares de miles y
cerramos en Estados Unidos porque el
país continúa pendiente de los
resultados definitivos de las elecciones
de medio término que se celebraron el
martes la atención en estos momentos
está puesta sobre el avance del conteo
en Arizona y Nevada que pueden decantar
el control del senado Cristóbal Vázquez
nuestro corresponsal en Washington nos
amplía
pues definitivamente en Nevada y en
Arizona es donde se está demorando la
elección para definir quién se queda con
la mayoría en cámara de representantes y
senado de hecho medios locales están
diciendo que Precisamente en Arizona
quedan todavía 300.000 votos por contar
sobre todo en el condado de maricopa muy
cercano a la ciudad de Phoenix donde
votaron muchas personas y lo hicieron
por correo pero en vez de enviar ese
voto por correo de forma anticipada pues
llevaron su sobre el mismo día de la
lección y esto ha demorado el conteo en
ese estado las cosas están de la
siguiente forma el senado en este
momento los demócratas tienen 48 escaños
los republicanos 49 en el senado
Precisamente lo que están diciendo los
pronósticos es que Nevada pues va a ser
un estado que van a ganar los
republicanos el republicano va a ganar
ese estado según las proyecciones
Arizona a pesar de que no se ha
terminado de contar la mayoría de los
votos le dan ese a los demócratas al
demócratas Entonces la cosa quedaría
dependiendo únicamente de lo que pase en
Georgia porque recordemos que de haber
un empate de 50 escaños republicanos 50
demócratas el voto el escaño de la
vicepresidenta Camila Harris es el que
le daría la mayoría Entonces al partido
demócrata en cuanto a la cámara en este
momento los demócratas tienen aseguradas
200 4 sillas los republicanos 211 sillas
están muy cerca lograr esa cifra mágica
de 218 votos sillas para lograr la
mayoría y en cuanto a gobernaciones 22
gobernaciones han ganado los demócratas
en esta elección y 24 los republicanos
hay que Resaltar que ha habido cierta
tensión en en internamente en el partido
republicano porque pues hay tropa ha
salido públicamente a criticar a medios
que lo hayan apoyado durante su su sus
últimos años de política como es el
Western pues estos medios están
énfasis y están apoyando ahora aún más a
ROM de santis que se perfila como
precandidato presidencial y Donald Trump
pues ha lanzado varios ataques
públicamente al candidato y Burger dueño
de estos medios de comunicación lo que
argumentan los republicanos internamente
es que faltó más trabajo faltó más
seguimiento en el partido republicano y
que es hora ya de dejar la dependencia
de Donald Trump como líder del partido
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]